goldie hawn
the greatest living woman on the planet
who i was lucky enough to do a movie
with yes
and bonded with her so hard she i know i
remember i had the best time with her
she's the most magnanimous woman and i
feel like i was getting to meet my idol
and how did you feel when i mean she's
goldie han yeah she is an icon yeah how
was that when you're a little kid with
your mom interesting
very interesting there's there's there's
there's it's like a roller coaster right
but my mom is a roller coaster she's
like a tornado i always say she's like
this like
tornado of like rainbows that like
doesn't destroy anything it just sort of
like comes in it's like wild and happy
and crazy and then gone you know you're
like where was she um
and she's like that with people so
sometimes for me when i was younger it
was like
you know and
people would take the attention away
from whether we were together and mom is
so i mean she doesn't know a stranger
she's so loving that she wants to give
everybody the time
kurt is the opposite
so kurt's like yeah
nope no thanks i'm with my kids
and that always made me feel so good and
so when they were together there was a
rule was like
we're with our kids we're not gonna get
into like signing autographs or taking
it's like they've stayed very focused
which actually when we were younger and
didn't understand it made us feel really
good because
you know they they were very
they were clear that the intention was
to be present with us
so i i think
but my mom
you know it depends on which way the
wind is blowing how she feels about this
like a perfect story is we it was the
mets
yankee subway series
that my cousin was playing in matt
franco and so we went to go see watch my
cousin and kurt was like all right
here's what we're gonna do i mean you
know world series it's like put your hat
on goldie put your hat on we're putting
our hat on head down
we're going right to our seats when we
get there you know people recognize
whatever so we're all like ready for
that plan like we're gonna get to the
seat and like my mom somehow gets lost
no hat and and next thing you know
people are going goldie and my mom's
like hi
and like the whole and we're like okay
and kurt you know you that's my mom you
just have to
you know and so
you love it and it's so true because
like kurt russell
he's such a cool guy i feel like i
wouldn't be offended i would that tone
yeah sure of course kurt russell yeah
and goldie is that
ray of sunshine so you want that warmth
from her and i have to talk to you about
rom-coms as someone who
at one point was almost pigeonholed from
rom-coms and you're in some of the best
rom-coms thanks and i love your rom-com
so much i love them too i i have this
thing with the rom-com though which it
was always like
i personally think the best
ones are so rooted and grounded
um but i find that when you get
pigeonholed or people want you in this
in the system to be like okay you're
going to do this and then you do it
you're always like no no no no it was
supposed to be like this like we wrote
it like this it's like they just want to
kind of dumb it down and make it too
bright and too perfect and put the bows
on it yeah and honestly i find that what
i always found was that i would try to
push the envelope and then it was like
you know no like we're not gonna do a
raid at our rom-com and then if you're
like you know a dude you can make a
rom-com that's a rated r and people get
excited by it and they want to push the
envelope and you're like for for for
things that are more female focused i
was always like we should try doing the
same thing as a lot of the sort of male
driven
we can make fun of ourselves we can
laugh at ourselves we can push the
envelope a little bit
um
and that's that's like the rom-com i'm
still interested in making i need
whatever movie you're gonna make next
because i love your movies
[Applause]
[Music]